Speaker 1: Joe Rogan and Dr. Phil have been
spreading the fake news story of fentanyl
candy. It is Halloween, so it seems like an
appropriate day to do the story. This is one
that has become very popular. Donald Trump
has been spreading it at his rallies. Others
have been repeating it. Drug dealers are going to
poison and kill your kids by disguising fentanyl
as candy. Sadly, it is not true, but it is
still being repeated. Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: Those pills look exactly like the pills
that you get at the pharmacy. And what they're
doing now, Joe, is they're putting them in these
pastel colors. I think I sent you some of those,
Jimmy, in the pastel colors. They're making
them look like these candies that the kids get.
And kids are going to see these things around
and pick them up and think they're like.
Sweet tarts or whatever and bite into them. If
I was a parent, I would go to the store and buy
every kind of candy I could find. And as soon
as my kids came home from trick or treating,
I would take their pumpkin and dump it into the
trash and then fill it back up with candy I knew
was good and hand it back to them. I wouldn't let
them take a single piece of candy from trick or
treating because you don't know what's in there.
Speaker 6: That was always the fear, right? When
we were kids. Someone's going to sneak in.
Speaker 5: We thought there'd be a razor
blade on an apple or something.
Speaker 6: I saw this going around,
but I heard a lot of people push them
back at the couple days after this.
Speaker 1: Jamie rightly suspects
that this may not be a real story.
Speaker 6: Made major headlines because they
were filmed to say no. Who's the expert?
I don't. I'm just. There was a lot of hubbub
about this viral picture because this one out,
the D.A. was talking about it. But then I read
there was like no evidence that this was real.
Exactly. Was this. That's what I read. Well, let's
scroll down and see what they say in terms of
looks like candy. Did DEA administrator Allen or
Anne Milgram told CBS News. In fact, some of the
drug traffickers have nicknamed it sweet tart
Skittles. DEA alert didn't mention Halloween,
but fears about rainbow fentanyl and the holiday
went viral. De de de de de de de. Warning meets
skepticism from drug experts. Drug policy experts
contacted by NPR agreed there's no new fentanyl
threat this Halloween. Many are also skeptical
the DEA has original warning. They don't believe
that Mexican drug cartels and street dealers have
launched any new campaign targeting children. I
don't see any evidence that the DEA has
produced that supports that conjecture.
Speaker 5: I don't think they're targeting
children. I think the fact that they are
making these things in pastel colors.
Yeah. Make children vulnerable, too.
Speaker 1: But Dr. Phil, you just said
they're going to hand these out at
Halloween and you've got to swap your kids candy.
Speaker 5: Picking these things up if you want to
argue over the the word targeting.
Speaker 1: Well,
there's a lot implicit in that word.
Speaker 5: If a child picks up something.
Speaker 1: Where how.
Speaker 5: That. Look, you know.
Speaker 1: On the floor, drug dealers are
going to leave fentanyl on the ground.
Speaker 5: I said that young girl that I
was talking about took three quarters of
a pill or one quarter of a pill and
three quarters of it was left in her
drawer. Yeah. If she has a a younger sister.
Speaker 1: Right. Very specific hypothetical.
So let's break this down. Why do right wingers
love this story? It's a way to attack Joe Biden.
That's that's the origin of this story. And you
might say, David, how on earth does fentanyl candy
serve as a way to attack Joe Biden? Here's
how they do it. There's fentanyl in candy,
which came in through the border, which was opened
by Joe Biden. So fentanyl candy is Biden's fault
and he hates kids who are going to be poisoned
by fentanyl, as they pronounce it, which is
part of how he doesn't care about kids. Now, you
would think that Rogan would realize this is the
exact same thing as with the cannabis edibles.
There was a time, as we saw more states legalize
cannabis recreationally where people say, you
know, a lot of these edibles just look like a
chocolate bar. It's very, very dangerous. Kids
aren't going to know. They're just going to say,
hey, chocolate, this is good. Next thing
you know, they'll be high as a kite. I'm
guessing Rogan rejected that then because it
made no sense. But he is not really applying
the same skepticism here. Although good for him
for at least looking up an article. First of all,
this doesn't pass the sniff test. The idea that
drug dealers would just dish out free drugs either
as a goof during trick or treating, or just
would leave drugs around when the whole point
is to sell the drugs for money doesn't make any
sense. Drug dealers want to make money. There's
no financial benefit to dishing out fentanyl laced
candy to children which might kill them. How are
you making money from that? It doesn't make any
sense whatsoever. Now, if you do some Googling,
you will find some stories of drug dealers using
candy, packaging and putting drugs in there. And
you can get a resealing machine to make it look
like the Skittles package or whatever was never
open. But they're not doing this to then hand
out at Halloween. They're just trying to do this
to get it through the border or authorities or
whatever, where police would see it and say, Oh,
it just looks like a package of Skittles. Is it
hypothetically, theoretically possible that your
Skittles bag that has actually been emptied and
refilled with some kind of drug and then sealed,
it could be misplaced and end up in the hands of
a kid. Sure, that's theoretically possible. That's
not new. I hate to break it to you, but if you
Google. What do ecstasy pills look like with MDMA?
For decades they have looked like candy. They've
got heart shaped ones and they've got this that it
is not new and it is not a real thing that kids
are just going, Oh, sweet tarts, put them in my
mouth. It's a fake story. And understand that the
origin is to criticize Biden about the border.
We'll have the clip I played on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.